[Música]
y justamente para hablar de información
económica se encuentra en el estudio mi
compañero Juan Pablo lucumí Juan Pablo
bienvenido vamos a iniciar con el más
reciente informe de la ocd con un futuro
para América Latina que no es muy
positivo Así es Valentina Buenas noches
pues en la nueva edición de su informe
bianual la organización para la
cooperación y el desarrollo económicos
prevé que para el 2023 la desaceleración
económica sea contundente Europa será el
más afectado pero ya revisaremos los
datos de nuestra región primero veamos
el panorama mundial la organización
Espera que el pib global caiga del 3,1%
que se espera que alcance este año al
2,7% en 2023 si venimos a América Latina
pues a esta región en lo ocurrido del
año le fue mejor de lo esperado debido a
un buen desempeño de exportaciones de
algunas materias primas que son más
ricas acá en nuestra región y todo esto
en el contexto de la guerra en Ucrania
pero el 2023 no será igual la economía
más afectada de latinoamérica latina
será la colombiana pues se espera que su
pib pase del 8,1% que alcanzará este año
al 1,2% en 2023 se espera también que
Argentina y chile crezcan sólo un 0,5%
el próximo año y Brasil un 1,2% frente
al 2,8 de este año el país que menos se
vería afectado sería Perú con un
crecimiento de tan solo un punto menos
que en este 2022 según la organización
este panorama se debe al endurecimiento
de las condiciones financieras mundiales
el retiro de la mayoría de las ayudas
Fiscales y la disminución de los precios
de las materias primas Pues sí poco
alentador este panorama vamos a
Argentina porque el gobierno de ese país
convocó a distintas entidades para
monitorear la formación de precios en la
nación Valentina hoy se reunieron
entidades empresariales sindicales
también de defensa del consumidor
organismos públicos universidades y
representantes de las provincias para
definir la agenda de trabajo del
Observatorio de precios del país esta
entidad fue creada en 2014 pero desde
2016 no ha tenido actividad las
asociaciones venían poniendo más bien le
venían pidiendo al gobierno la
reactivación de el observatorio con el
fin de tener acceso a la información
sobre los precios y la disponibilidad de
insumos y bienes y servicios todo esto
mientras el país viene registrando
crecientes datos de inflación que
expertos esperan que supere el 100%
antes de finalizar este año y mientras
hoy se registró una jornada de huelgas
en Argentina de movimientos de izquierda
que piden mejores salarios y de que cada
vez son más comunes estas jornadas de
paro Juan Pablo vamos a atravesar el
Atlántico nos vamos hasta Italia porque
la nueva primera ministra la
ultraderechista Georgia melón y presentó
hoy el plan económico su nuevo plan
económico Así es Valentina las
modificaciones presupuestarias de
Georgia meloni muestran un claro cambio
político en el país el plan se enfoca en
dos frentes iniciativas so económicas
para familias de bajos ingresos y ayudas
a la industria italiana a crecer a pesar
de la crisis energética provocada por la
invasión rusa de Ucrania el plan también
Busca eliminar una renta básica y una
reforma de pensiones de hace una década
que meloni y sus aliados de derecha han
atacado durante mucho tiempo pero
escuchemos a la primera italiana
hablando de los números pues lo que como
prometimos la mayor parte de esta ley de
presupuesto es para brindar seguridad
económica a empresas y familias y se
destina a abordar las altas facturas de
energía con un presupuesto total de 35
mil millones de euros hay unos 21.000
millones destinados a solucionar los
mayores costos energéticos Juan Pablo
nos desplazamos Ahora hasta el
continente africano porque en Sudáfrica
hubo una nueva jornada de protestas
masivas Así es esta es una segunda ronda
después de que la asociación de
servicios públicos que representa a más
de 200.000 servidores públicos declarará
inicialmente una disputa con el gobierno
Y es que son miles los usted estar en
distintas partes del país pidiendo que
el salario mínimo aumente en un 10%.
previamente las negociaciones no
llegaron a ninguna resolución y el
gobierno de Rama fosa decidió
unilateralmente un incremento del 3% lo
que generó la protesta el gobierno
también había implementado un principio
de no trabajo no pago para la persona
que pues no trabaja precisamente no le
daban su salario pues esto para limitar
las movilizaciones Pero esto no impidió
la protesta del día de hoy y
multitudinaria además Bueno vamos con
Los indicadores económicos de la jornada
Valentina iniciamos con Wall Street
porque la jornada fue positiva para los
inversores las sólidas ganancias
registradas por varios minoristas de
Cara a los feriados por Acción de
Gracias impulsó las ganancias de varias
compañías siguiendo la senda alcista de
Estados Unidos las bolsas europeas
cerraron también con ganancias los
índices de Londres París y Frankfurt
estuvieron en positivo nuestra región en
cambio cerró en terreno mixto solo con
el índice principal de referencia de
Brasil con una caída
0,81%. Juan Pablo Pues a usted muchas
gracias por esta ampliación económica lo
invito a que se quede con nosotros
Porque vamos a directo